welcome to this video playing Rafael
back wants but could be something with
Baku maybe okay well this is the minion
flag so let's see it opens a Cillian
again what is going on the night off
yeah when I plea for your father bliss
can then normally play this Bishop b-29
it feels that this is some something
that can be played with them the limited
knowledge that I have maybe this first
interesting very early exchange I think
perhaps I'm not not not the expert here
very quickly played all that maybe it is
something known i don't i don't know
maybe Brooke chicks now this is far more
natural yeah transposition a not
transposition and transformation of this
position to to something different after
95 we have a an altered porn structure
hmm interesting and what she wants so
ideally a night on you five against them
the bishop only two but try to not allow
that now we're taking what the bishop
now is not a good idea so I'm probably
probably go back yeah 94 Bishop g4
wasn't really a great a great concept
he wants to go but should be five but
this is really so great don't know yeah
the problem is when I play those efore
open Sicilian positions my experience is
very limited so I sort of have to
reinvent the wheel sometimes stuff that
is probably totally obvious to regular
Sicilian players or one year for players
I need to need to find out with the
board
my idea was to to double but this is not
going to happen anyway yeah they porn is
vulnerable here
that's not a good position the Queen c4
was so this I should really overlooked
mmm ok yeah must the a pond not good
okay i have some activity on the
kingside it's not enough but i can just
kick and just play g6 and l5 and this
basically stops everything ok
without any any drastic measures I'm not
going to survive here anyway maybe
g-force wasn't really great yeah exactly
because of that ok I don't I don't need
to you don't need to trade I can play g5
now this is it your take ya time morning
and this makes it very easy can play a
for now and then it's very easy just a
very bad game
yeah I shouldn't give up the porn i mean
give up is the wrong word i just check I
just overlooked Queen the Queen move
them to see form
I might as well resign him they are
twins if I it wasn't a great position in
any case white resides and probably
night maybe 95 wasn't wasn't very well
timed when I want to play this I can
probably prepare it better I don't know
and it's difficult I as mentioned i
don't really know those positions to
what i have many other things that I can
do here like how it's a queen here or
some move I don't I don't know what's
best here I simply don't know this is
also not a bad position for white I mean
definitely not but it's a it should be
played better than I did this is all
probably not not very good and Quincy
for was the very annoying moved to face
computer likes wide after Bishop g5 yeah
it's a bit difficult I really didn't
feel at home here probably after this I
should try to to get something going on
the queenside
quickly I actually thought that this is
the calm suggestion that a five would be
good but some other computer likes queen
age 3m and now the evaluation goes down
to zero point something hard to say I
definitely have lost the thread after
Queen c4 after that um yeah I'm just
clearly worse and he did a good job in
wrapping this up okay thanks for
watching